Aaron you played a lot of the division
and just the other day massive
entertainment Ubisoft announced the
division to will be showing up III so
that got us thinking especially cuz I'm
replaying the first game recently that
got us thinking what we want in the
sequel when we see it at e3 so we wanted
to talk about things that the first game
kind of did well maybe could have done
better but the main thing right off the
bat that we want division 2 to do is to
learn from the updates they made to the
first game right yeah it's really
important that they build off their
progress with their community this is a
really hard lesson that destiny to be
learning right now all those quality of
life stuff all the quality life stuff
that they did from destiny one didn't
make it into the sequel and they're just
trying to get back to how good it was at
the end of the last game so with the
division going up through the 1.8 Update
and the global events and the dark isn't
changes they cannot erase that progress
and that trust that they built with
their community so it's really important
that the sequel starts where they left
off and and goes from there
yeah use it as like a kind of
jumping-off block rather than something
oh maybe we'll eventually get to that
with sequel as well I'm speaking of
destiny too I think obviously that's an
easy comparison because of the way these
games function kind of as those life
style games right or Diablo right like
obviously the division is kind of really
inspired by Diablo I want to talk about
the looting the loot crime throughout
the game level-cap in the first game not
counting the dark zone level is 30 right
and the whole time you're getting there
you're getting common rare every once in
a while you get an orange item but very
rarely and usually it's after a boss and
late game events one thing destiny to
did well I think is it introduced a
better stream of loot taken King kind of
improved on destiny 1 but with the
division 2 I personally would like to
see that steady stream of loot
especially if they're inspired by Diablo
which i think does a great job of you
could be level like 40 in Diablo like 30
away from the level cap and still get a
legendary that was part of a set I'd
like to see more of that throughout the
division so the grind to get to level
cap before you hit late-game stuff kind
of gives you a taste of what some of
those Legendary's might be like or maybe
like division has set armor I'd like to
start gathering that before late-game
and then later on I get started mid
maxing it but I don't know did you feel
that the division was like rewarding
enough throughout the boot grind to get
to late-game
it did feel like the original divisions
suffered from end game design so it felt
like and this is
a problem a lot of games again were
chasing destiny with endgame that they
felt the need to have that content there
after people were done with the base and
what it really did was that I feel like
it like ripped a lot of the guts out of
the main game and just kind of shoved it
on the head and it made it less of a
good game it wasn't as full of a game so
what you're saying about the luke ride
being there persistently throughout the
entire game is very important to give
the players that sense of reward how
they tackle endgame after that is up in
the air I don't even know if endgame
like makes the division better than it
would be if it was just a cohesive
package yeah but I mean I would expect
them to in the sequel maybe they could
focus more of the endgame on the dark
zone and make a lot more changes to the
dark zone make the dark zone a scarier
place make it to have different enemies
make it out of different logic why are
we why is the dark zone any scarier than
any other place in the game if it just
has the same enemies and you kind of
touched on this but with the most recent
update to the division which is one
point eight the patch they made a lot of
quality and lot of life improvements
well throughout the whole lifespan of
scheme they've been doing that and it's
a much better game than when it started
just in terms of how it plays like your
talk about the dark zone now you have to
actually declare that your rogue before
you just shoot someone in the face you
were saying you hope that much like
Destiny's PvP they might kind of erase
your stats during PvP to kind of level
the dark zone playing field yeah I mean
I think you know we've had a lot of
games recently that are popular that are
fair because they're unfair like hub G
right you never know what gun you're
gonna pick up but when you pick up a gun
it has to be a gun and and one of the
problems with the divisions dark zone is
that it's too much of an RPG and you
have godlike players who just pull away
from the pack yeah and even if they even
with the one point updated 1.8 update if
they declare themselves rogue you might
not stand any chance against these
people right so it has to be fair you
have to have an environment where you
know it's it's scary it's tense but you
shoot somebody they go down and you
can't have this thing where you shoot
another player and they are so much
better than you they can just shrug it
off and you stand no chance because then
why would you ever go in the dark zone
it was so frustrating for players and if
you play destiny a lot you know like
iron banner events allow you to bring
your stats into PvP that's
point of them maybe the division can
figure out something like that but
speaking of game modes the division has
introduced a ton in terms of just past
the basic luk ride
they have skirmish now which to the 4v4
PvP mode they which that itself is just
kind of like you know who can get more
kills it's a kind of basic then they
have resistance which is like a horde
mode where you're you and two other
people are defending against you know
hordes of Riker's rioters and cleaners
but then they also have underground kind
of like dungeons like procedurally
generated chalice dungeons I don't know
it's make a weird random blood-borne
reference they added so many different
ways to play this game do you want them
to just start off right the view think
they'll start right away with those
modes included yeah so you mentioned the
underground if they built up underground
and they're randomly generated dungeons
that could make a sequel to the division
really stand out I think some other
games recently again going back to the
direct comparison with Destiny's
infinite forest sort of tried to sell
people something like that and fell way
short of what the underground DLC was
yeah so if the division two can build
off of that randomly generated dungeons
and and really make experience is
different for players particularly I was
were talking before in the endgame that
would add a lot of longevity so building
on top of that I think would be
essential for this game and probably the
last thing we both want to touch on so
in Luke Rhine games like this it's easy
to ignore story right I mean when you
have people coming over your comms in
the division they're super cheesy
they're they like idolize you they're
like hey I know you're busy division
agent Aaron or whatever but could you
saw something for me like I don't it's
easy to ignore that but at the same time
the world of the division sets such an
awesome stage like in Division one it's
you know Christmastime in New York City
right after this this virus broke out
because it was like spread all on money
during Black Friday it's a cool premise
and like it you want to like see some
badass store you come out of it where
the division agents are sent in and then
you have like these moral gray areas
where you're fighting different
different factions of just people that
rose up and these different enemies that
are actually kind of you know
interlocking in terms of their interests
I want to see the division to make good
on the potential we saw with exploring
that kind of New York or wherever to
happens to be sides you have anywhere
you want it to be set where well you had
some theories on where you think yeah I
mean I would
because they do in the first game
reference other cities being hit by
something like this I don't know I
they went to San Francisco with
watchdogs to I mean maybe London would
be cool when's the last time you saw
well Ubisoft did London with a Sanskrit
syndicate but that was like Industrial
Revolution London maybe they'll go to
London I'm like it has to be for the it
to be the division I feel like it has to
be this big like capitalist City so I'm
wondering I don't think they'll stay in
New York I think that they've tried that
and it was cool it's a really cool
setting but I want them to go somewhere
else like who knows if it'll even be
winter maybe it'll be like a summertime
place that's just rundown more like the
last of us it's really cool thinking
about that but my main thing is I want
them to make good on you know a story
that supports the Luke grind even though
I'm really gonna be playing for the
lucra and I think one thing that really
could support a good story in the sequel
is first of all showing up at the right
moment so in the last game you should
have after all the good stuff had
happened and you never got to know
anybody post outbreak yeah yeah you were
just left with their stuff which in
there echoes which is way less
interesting but the other thing is maybe
a faction system dealing with the
survivors the people like the cleaners
and even rioters in the last game had
fairly like logical reasons why they
were doing what they were doing and this
kill-all approach really took away from
the story yeah it's like the the
cleaners were a bunch of blue-collar
workers who saw everybody around them
die and realize they had to kill the
virus live by literally burning it
before everybody else died and you just
you know you just walk up and you kill
them like the rioters you walk across
them at times and they clearly say we
did not kill this person we're just
trying to survive and you kill them it's
like why not get into these factions and
and who they are and maybe have to
choose like GTA style maybe some parts
of the city become more or less hostile
depending on your decisions yeah be
interesting for them to like maybe even
give you a who's really the good guy
story kind of like Shadow the Colossus
or something because you are this
assistant government agency sent in to
essentially be the police when the
police are just wiped out and then the
rioters the cleaners the bikers are all
the vigilantes that we usually play as
so it's really there's a lot of
potential to tell a story from the side
of the governing agency and whether
they're really the good guys but I mean
in general I think me and you can agree
I think with the division - I think
massive entertainment and Ubisoft and
like
all the people that they're working in
conjunction with from like Bucharest
Ubisoft Singapore like everywhere
they're all working on this game and
they really just need to use the
division 1.8 Update as a diving board
rather than saying oh let's work back to
something like that two years after two
comes out we need to avoid the mistake
destiny made we need to come out and
like prove to this twenty million people
that have been playing the first game
for two years that their time is gonna
be well-spent right away when the game
comes out and who knows when it's gonna
come out like I'm predicting maybe
spring 2019 for gonna show it at e3 this
year but who knows if that will actually
happen yeah they've been working with
their community to get to this point
it's actually very surprising that the
games had a resurgence I think some of
that is fatigue for other games I mean
at the end of the day their community is
there for that min/max loot chase the
people who are still around and they
want that in the next game they want
meaningful weapons they want probably
more meaningful like outfits I don't
know how many walnut beanies did you
collect in the last game scarves and
bomber jackets yeah I mean I like the
aesthetic but I would like some
variation you get the late game you have
like riot gear on but before that I'd
like to see some variation maybe bring
forward some of the use of that gear
from the survival of DLC yeah and then
yeah not lose that trust that they've
worked so hard to build and carry that
forward yes who knows maybe we'll see a
teaser before e3 2018 but we know for
sure
based on what Ubisoft said that we will
see the division 2 at e3 and then we'll
know more around then Aaron thank you so
much for talking about the division 2
and what we want out of it thanks
you
[Music]